Gaza Stadt, einen Monat später.
Der Schweizer Pierre Krähenbühl
soll es richten.
Er ist Generalkommissar der UNRWA
und somit Schutzherr
der Vereinten Nationen über 5 Mio.
palästinensische Flüchtlinge.
Sie bringen Hoffnung?
Leute wenden sich an UNRWA
und sagen: "Gebt uns Hoffnung!"
Denn:
Man kann weder diesen Ort verlassen,
noch kann man jedes Mal
den Krieg überleben -
es gab viele Tote und Verletzte.
Jetzt muss es
eine Zukunftsperspektive geben -
und UNRWA kann diese geben.
Warum man nicht aufgeben darf,
wenn andere verzweifeln,
und wie man den Verzweifelten
Mut macht -
davon handelt dieser Film.
Wehmütiges Klavierlied
Nur selten ist Pierre Krähenbühl
in seiner Wohnung in Ostjerusalem.
Alles ist bescheiden.
Er hastet
von Konferenz zu Konferenz,
Gespräche mit Geldgebern,
Politikern, informieren, lobbyieren.
Und die Familie:
zu Hause in der Schweiz.
Dass dieser Mann über ein Budget
von mehr als 1 Mrd. $ gebietet
und über 35'000 Angestellte verfügt,
würde man kaum vermuten.
Nur selten bleiben ihm Momente,
das Erlebte zu verarbeiten.
Viel Leid, viel Elend hat er gesehen.
Persönlich sitzt das sehr tief.
Als ich
während des Krieges Ende Juli
das Shifa Spital
in Gaza besuchte und dort sah,
wie viele Kinder verletzt
in den Betten und Korridoren lagen,
und ich
die Augen und Blicke der Eltern sah,
mit denen ich mich
zutiefst identifizieren kann,
weil ich auch Söhne habe,
konnte ich mir gut vorstellen,
was es heisst,
als Eltern den Eindruck zu haben,
man konnte seine eigenen Kinder
in diesem Krieg nicht schützen.
Das ist hart.
Ja, das ist hart.
Und ich glaube auch,
dass es sehr wichtig ist,
sich an solche Sachen
nie zu gewöhnen.
Gewöhnung
ist vielleicht der grösste Feind.
Die Gefahr, Krieg und Gewalt
als gegeben hinzunehmen, ist gross.
Bald ein Jahrhundert
dauert der Konflikt im Heiligen Land
zwischen Israeli und Palästinensern.
Ein Ende ist nicht absehbar.
Doch die Öffentlichkeit
ist überdrüssig des ewigen Streits,
verdrängt ihn und will nichts hören.
Pierre Krähenbühl möchte, dass
die Welt wieder zuhört und hinschaut.
Hallo.
Es geht nach Gaza.
Für die Fahrt
von Jerusalem bis zur Grenze
brauchen wir
wenig mehr als eine Stunde -
und doch
führt sie uns in eine andere Welt.
Pierre Krähenbühl will, dass die
UNRWA-Schulen wieder geöffnet werden.
Er will Normalität schaffen.
Aber was ist schon Normalität
an einem Ort wie Gaza?
Die Tatsache, dass jetzt
Kinder in Gaza aufwachsen,
ohne je
einen Israeli getroffen zu haben -
dass sie von Israelis
nur die Drohnen und die Angriffe
und die Angst kennen, ist etwas,
das für die Zukunft der Region
ganz besonders problematisch ist.
It will be irrelevant.
We will be there by 8, or ...
Yeah, it looks ...
... good.
We're getting closer,
so I'll see you in a while.
Gaza: Eine riesige Mauer umgibt
ein Gebiet kaum grösser als Genf,
Pierre Krähenbühls Heimatkanton.
1,8 Mio. Menschen
sind darin eingesperrt.
Gaza wird häufig
als Freiluftgefängnis bezeichnet.
Als ich das erste Mal Gaza besuchte,
fragte mich
eine junge israelische Soldatin,
wohin ich eigentlich wolle,
und ich dachte:
"Ich wusste nicht, dass man noch
woanders hin kann als nach Gaza."
Das ist wohl Teil dieses
etwas merkwürdigen Gaza-Umfeldes.
Ich muss hier aussteigen.
Nur der UN-Diplomat
darf mit dem Wagen über die Grenze.
Am Kontrollpunkt
ist dann auch Schluss mit Filmen.
Wir sind in einer Sicherheitszone.
Auf palästinensischer Seite
schalten wir die Kamera wieder ein.
Pierre Krähenbühl steigt
in ein gepanzertes UN-Fahrzeug um.
Aus Sicherheitsgründen
müssen wir unseren Transport
selbst organisieren.
Doch schon nach wenigen hundert
Metern verlieren wir den Anschluss.
Gleich beim Checkpoint
der palästinensischen Behörden
bleiben wir stecken.
Die Papiere sind nicht vollständig.
Während unser lokaler Mitarbeiter
beim Innenministerium die Papiere
besorgt, heisst es für mich abwarten.
Mit gut 3 Std. Verspätung
geht es endlich weiter.
Auf dem Weg nach Gaza Stadt
fahren wir durch Shejaiya.
Der Aussenbezirk
wurde flächendeckend zerbombt.
Er liegt nahe der Grenzmauer.
Von hier haben die Palästinenser
zahlreiche Tunnel gegraben.
Nicht für den Schmuggel,
sondern um Israel anzugreifen,
wie die Armee sagt.
Die Vergeltung ist vernichtend.
Doch auf den Ruinen wehen schon
wieder trotzig die Fahnen der Hamas.
Düstere Klänge
Ziel der israelischen Angriffe
waren auch zahlreiche Moscheen.
Sie sollen - so die Begründung -
der Hamas
als Waffenlager gedient haben.
Die al-Susi Moschee
war gleichzeitig eine Koranschule
mit einer grossen Bibliothek.
Der Muezzin kommt auf uns zu, als er
bemerkt, dass wir deutsch sprechen.
Alles kaputt.
Er selbst hat vor 25 Jahren
in Deutschland gelebt.
Alles kaputt.
Von diesen gibt es nur 2 oder 4.
Alles ist kaputt.
Alles kaputt.
Ungefähr 600-700 Korane -
alle kaputt.
Warum?
Alles kaputt.
Mitten in Gaza Stadt sind die Spuren
des 50 Tage dauernden Krieges
weit weniger deutlich zu spüren.
Hier liegt das Hauptquartier
des UNRWA-Flüchtlingshilfswerkes -
gesichert wie eine Festung.
Pierre Krähenbühl
trifft eine Gruppe von Bauingenieuren
und Sozialarbeiterinnen.
Sie mussten die letzten Wochen
hart arbeiten.
Dabei
liegt das Meiste noch vor ihnen.
Der Chef ist stolz auf seine Leute.
Ihr habt meinen grössten Respekt
für all die Arbeit,
die ihr geleistet habt.
Sie ist ganz entscheidend
in dieser Phase
nach dem schrecklichen Konflikt,
den ihr durchgemacht habt.
Sie sind an der Front
bei den Vertriebenen,
die ihre Häuser verloren haben.
Sie berechnen
das Ausmass der Schäden.
Die Zahlen, die sie zusammenstellen,
gehen an die internationale
Gemeinschaft und entscheiden darüber,
wie viel Geld für den Wiederaufbau
nach Gaza fliesst.
Wenn wir in die Hauptstädte gehen
und darüber berichten,
was hier geschehen ist, machen wir
es den Politikern schwerer,
ihre Aufmerksamkeit
anderen Krisen zuzuwenden.
Unsere Rolle ist es,
ihre ganze Aufmerksamkeit
auf Gaza zu lenken,
denn die internationale Gemeinschaft
ist auch verantwortlich für das,
was hier passiert ist.
Weil sie die Leute
nicht genug geschützt hat
und weil das Ausmass der Zerstörung
so riesig ist.
Krähenbühl ist beunruhigt.
Er weiss, wenn jetzt
die internationale Gemeinschaft
nicht massiv Druck
auf Israel und die Hamas ausübt,
passiert gar nichts.
Bisher kommt kaum Baumaterial für
den Wiederaufbau nach Gaza hinein,
da die Kriegsparteien
einander keine Zugeständnisse machen.
Wenn das so weitergeht,
dann sind wir
in 2 Monaten noch immer da,
kein Baumaterial kommt rein,
und die Leute
sitzen in ihren Trümmern.
Und das so kurz vor dem Winter
kann ich mir persönlich
gar nicht vorstellen.
Da will ich nicht mitspielen.
Da will ich, dass die Leute
konkret Aktivitäten von uns sehen,
konkrete Änderungen.
Aber das Langfristige
mit dem Wiederaufbau,
das hängt
von der politischen Ebene ab.
Da muss ganz klar sein:
Man darf nicht mit
der Zukunft dieser Menschen spielen.
Während Pierre Krähenbühl
zu einem geschlossenen Meeting
weitereilt,
schaue ich mich auf dem Gelände um.
Die UNRWA kümmert sich
um die Ausbildung der Palästinenser.
Und so findet sich auch
eine Schule auf dem Gelände.
Eigentlich ist es
ein College für ältere Schüler.
Doch die müssen jetzt
den Platz mit Kindern teilen,
deren Schulen zerbombt wurden oder
Flüchtlingen als Unterkunft dienen.
Sie singen ein fröhliches Lied.
Unterricht gibt es
so kurz nach dem Krieg nicht.
Nicht einmal
über die Schrecken der letzten Wochen
sprechen die Betreuer
mit den Kindern.
3 Kriege haben die Mädchen
in ihren kurzen Leben erlitten.
Sie sollen
erst einmal wieder erfahren,
dass das Leben
nicht nur aus Tod und Angst besteht -
es kann auch Freude machen.
Das nächste Meeting zeigt mir,
wie stark
sich Pierre Krähenbühl engagiert.
Dass ihn die Mitarbeiter umarmen,
hat guten Grund:
3-mal war er während des Krieges
in Gaza. Das rechnen sie ihm hoch an.
Er ist nicht nur Chef,
er ist auch Freund.
Aber wo bleibt die Neutralität?
Wird er nicht selbst Partei?
Ich versuche sehr, diese wichtige
Neutralität zu bewahren, obgleich -
wie ich immer sage -
ich nicht neutral geboren wurde.
Aber ich bin hier,
um mich konzentriert zu engagieren
für die Würde und die Lage
der palästinensischen Flüchtlinge.
Für die Mitarbeiter
steht eine offene Fragerunde an.
Jeder kann vortragen,
was ihm am Herzen liegt.
Oft haben die Palästinenser
das Gefühl,
als Menschen 2. Klasse
behandelt zu werden.
Und so falsch ist der Eindruck nicht.
Die Öffentlichkeit hat sich
an die zahllosen Toten
unter den Palästinensern gewöhnt
und nimmt sie längst
schulterzuckend hin.
Pierre Krähenbühl will aufrütteln.
Das haben wir nie akzeptiert
und werden wir nie akzeptieren.
Die Welt muss wissen: Palästinenser
sind nicht einfach Statistik.
Das Leiden hier
ist wie überall auf der Welt.
Die Familien,
die unter den Kämpfen leiden,
haben die gleichen Hoffnungen,
Erwartungen und Pläne fürs Leben,
wie sonst wo.
Deswegen werden wir nie akzeptieren,
dass ihre Schicksale
einfach auf Zahlen reduziert werden.
Unverständliche Rufe
und Sirenenklänge
Auch UNRWA-Schulen waren Kampfzone -
das, obwohl viele Vertriebene
hier Zuflucht suchten.
Wo sollten sie auch hin?
Das Kriegsgebiet verlassen
konnten sie nicht.
Unter dem Schutz der UNRWA
glaubten sie sich sicher.
Doch dem war nicht so.
In diesem Fall galt der Angriff
einer Polizeistation.
Dabei wurde die daneben liegende
Schule auch getroffen.
Die israelische Armee
ist in der Lage,
mit höchster Präzision Ziele treffen.
Trotzdem hat sie in 7 Fällen
UNRWA-Schulen getroffen.
Warum kam es so oft
zu solchen Zwischenfällen?
Wir haben -
gerade um sie zu schützen -
die israelische Armee
z.B. 17-mal daran erinnert,
wo unsere Schule
in Dschabaliya ist.
33-mal haben wir
die Rafah-Schule notifiziert -
und doch kam es
zu diesen Zwischenfällen.
Das hat uns natürlich dazu gebracht,
diese Zwischenfälle
öffentlich zu verurteilen,
auch in den 2 Fällen
Rafah und Dschabaliya
Israel direkt
dafür verantwortlich zu machen
und Untersuchungen zu verlangen.
Der Beschuss ziviler Einrichtungen
verstösst gegen das Völkerrecht.
Es ist ein Kriegsverbrechen.
Allerdings es gab den Vorwurf,
Waffen seien
in den Schulen versteckt.
Doch auch das
lässt Pierre Krähenbühl nicht gelten,
denn er selbst war schockiert
und hatte die Funde
sofort öffentlich gemacht.
3-mal haben wir
während unseren eigenen Inspektionen
Waffen gefunden.
Die wurden von Gruppen
hier in Gaza dort gelagert.
Das haben wir öffentlich verurteilt.
Wir brachten das selber
an die Öffentlichkeit,
weil wir glaubten,
dass in dem Fall
nur Transparenz gerechtfertigt ist.
Das ist auch wichtig.
Die Welt weiss davon,
weil UNRWA das selber
mitgeteilt und verurteilt hat.
Bis heute dienen über 18 UNRWA-
Schulen als Flüchtlingslager.
An Unterricht ist nicht zu denken
solange es
keine anderen Unterkünfte gibt.
Die Zerstörung der Schulen
ist da fast das kleinere Problem.
32'000 Menschen
wohnen noch in den Schulhäusern.
Sie können nicht
einfach wieder rausgeworfen werden.
Do it again!
Der UNRWA-Chef
will aus erster Hand wissen,
wie es den Vertriebenen
ergangenen ist.
2 Frauen, die mit ihren Familien
aus dem Stadtteil Sheshaiya
geflohen sind, berichten ihm.
Ein Mitarbeiter dolmetscht.
Sie mussten ganz unverhofft flüchten
und konnten nichts mitnehmen.
Mit der Erzählung werden sie
von ihren Gefühlen überwältigt.
Alle Kinder auf der Welt sind
glücklich, nur unsere Kinder nicht.
Wo immer wir um Hilfe nachfragen
werden wir wie Bettler behandelt.
Man nimmt uns unseren Stolz weg.
Wir werden gedemütigt.
Selbst für ein kleines Stückchen
Brot müssen wir uns anstellen.
Da sind Sie sprachlos, wenn Sie
mit so viel konfrontiert werden?
Nein. Man muss immer gut zuhören.
Man versteht die Lage nur,
wenn man dem anderen zuhört.
Und hier wird viel mitgeteilt.
Wenn man richtig zuhört,
dann weiss man,
dass es auf dieser Erde
niemand verdient hat,
so etwas mitzuerleben.
Sie haben das jetzt mitgeteilt.
Sie sind schon
palästinensische Flüchtlinge -
und jetzt wurden sie
noch einmal vertrieben.
Die Lebensbedingungen
der Vertriebenen sind beengt.
4 Familien
teilen sich ein Klassenzimmer.
Allein die Familie Inteez
zählt 11 Personen.
Privatsphäre gibt es nicht.
Zumeist sind
nur Frauen und Kinder hier.
Die Männer sind weg.
So unter den Frauen,
das ist nichts für sie.
Einer der Söhne
will uns zu seinem Vater bringen.
Er lebt in seinem Haus -
oder was davon übrig geblieben ist.
Das Sha'af-Quartier ist arg zerstört.
Der Angriff kam in der Nacht -
ohne Vorwarnung.
Sie sprechen arabisch.
Der Vater, ein paar Freunde
und der Onkel, dem das Haus gehört,
sitzen hier herum.
Reparieren können sie nichts,
denn sie haben kein Baumaterial.
Der Vater erzählt vom Angriff.
Wir sassen in unseren Wohnungen.
Plötzlich wurde
das Haus neben uns bombardiert.
Da ist auch bei uns
das Dach eingestürzt.
Meine Kinder
wurden verletzt und schrien.
Und auch ich wurde am Fuss verletzt.
Die Trümmer
sind auf uns runtergestürzt.
3 Kinder meines Bruders
wurden getötet,
die anderen nur verletzt.
Jetzt lebt der Vater hier
und hat sich in den Trümmern
häuslich eingerichtet.
In die UNRWA-Schule
will er nicht zurück.
Glück im Unglück.
Eine Granate, die ins Haus einschlug,
ist nicht explodiert.
Die ist auch im Haus gelandet.
Wenn sie explodiert wäre,
wären wir alle umgekommen.
4 weitere Blindgänger sind hier
in der Gegend runter gegangen.
Wir können Gott dankbar sein,
dass wir nicht alle tot sind.
Wehmütige Klänge
Es war der schlimmste Krieg
der letzten Jahre,
den die Menschen in Gaza
erleiden mussten.
Dabei kann das Leben
auch hier beinahe idyllisch sein.
Der Strand ist
vielleicht der letzte Rückzugsort,
der das Elend vergessen lässt.
Es tönt absurd, aber die Zerstörung
kann auch ein Gutes haben:
Sie gibt den Konfliktparteien
die Chance, ihre Fehler zu überdenken
und neu anzufangen.
Gaza könnte ein anderer Ort sein.
Ich muss sagen:
Es tut der Seele gut,
wenn man ins Mittelmeer schauen
und sich entspannen kann.
Aber die Tatsache ist nun einmal:
Man kann in diese oder
in eine andere Richtung schauen,
doch die Zerstörung bleibt.
Das Elend und das Leiden bleiben.
Für Pierre Krähenbühl
kein Grund zu verzweifeln,
sondern ein Ansporn mehr,
für die Zukunft dieser Menschen
zu kämpfen.
Gäbe ich jetzt die Hoffnung auf,
hiesse das,
ich würde einfach akzeptieren,
dass Gewalt immer Recht hat.
Das kann ich nicht
und habe ich nie akzeptiert -
und ich werde auch heute
hier in Gaza nicht damit beginnen.
Vielleicht
scheitert Pierre Krähenbühl.
Aber Hoffnung
ist nicht die Überzeugung,
dass etwas gut ausgeht,
sondern die Gewissheit,
dass etwas Sinn macht -
egal wie es ausgeht.